les ont pas on s'installe comme ça gémit
casque je m'entends j'ai les retours
c'est formidable c'est bien ce nouveau
set up ainsi micron comment ça va vous
vous allez bien alors j'ai le cas c'est
que ça fait j'aime me semble le croire
ça lui faisait dans la libre antenne
aujourd'hui avec monsieur groupe qui va
vous paraître beaucoup de choses ça ça
arrivera ce sera le podcast dans
quelques temps on va se faire plus tôt
nous en deux vidéos donc j'enlève le
retour je ne m'entends plus est vous qui
m'entendent et voilà donc on se donnait
comme ça aussi de ce que le maître le
micro là pour que ça ne prenne pas la
moitié du visage voyez comme ça en plein
milieu du nigeria pour la radio ça
marche un peu moins maintenant
aujourd'hui on va parler de smartphones
une fois n'est pas coutume et on va
parler de smartphones qui rame je sais
pas si c'est votre cas vous mais il ya
beaucoup de smartphones qui au bout d'un
moment et bien commence à montrer un peu
des signes de faiblesse marche moins
bien vont beaucoup moins vite et ces
pays
l'idée aujourd'hui c'est de donner des
astuces concrètes pour savoir comment
rendre votre smartphone rapide tout de
suite beaucoup plus rapide immédiatement
on va voir des résultats et vous allez
voir au final c'est pas extrêmement
compliqué j'ai en tout huit points j'ai
une fête plus je levais du coût de la
cause du du micro g8 pour un vous donner
puis à la fin de la vidéo je devrais à
des bonus en plus des astuces en plus
des connaissances en plus donc c'est
vraiment cool
la toute première chose si ce n'est pas
déjà fait vous invite à vous abonner à
la chaîne puisque je donne des tutos 10
astuces comme celle-là je me présente
aussi beaucoup de nouveautés de
smartphones c'est des smartphones que je
vous ai déjà présenté il ya quelques
temps il y en aura d'autre n'aura
toujours ya des smartphones mais aussi
des mondes connectés des ordinateurs
plein d'astuces plein tuto des guides
d'achat c'est génial donc on me rejoint
on sent j'aille en symboles et ses
formidables alors aujourd'hui
eh bien il ya un programme qui est très
chargé donc on va essayer de faire au
mieux qu'on a c'est tout ça d'aller au
plus vite j'ai le redis en dessous donc
si je baisse les yeux ne vous inquiétez
pas c'est normal c'est pas mon promoteur
mais bon je dois voir un peu ce que j'ai
à vous dire j'ai donc des astuces l'on
vous aider à rendre votre smartphone
beaucoup moins local permet d'aller
beaucoup plus vite et pour votre confort
moi il ya quelques années j'avais un
iphone je sais plus lequel j'avais 16
gigaoctets de mémoire
j'étais obligé de supprimer deux
applications pour en installer une
c'était une galère absolue heureusement
aujourd'hui les stockage augmentent
aujourd'hui il ya beaucoup de solutions
mais il arrive que dans certains cas et
bien malgré tout avec le temps les
smartphones ram c'est comme ça c'est un
fait cp leader dit man a tout de suite
vous en bas en commentaire est ce que
votre smartphone ram
oui non pas du tout comment vous pouvez
y aller il ya plusieurs problèmes qui
peuvent faire ramer les smartphones
notamment le
d'avoir de nouvelles fonctionnalités qui
vont venir consommer davantage de
mémoire mais ça concerne surtout deux
points essentiels est ce qu'on appelle
la ram et le rhum
alors je sais c'est un peu pénible comme
sale arabe vous savez c'est l'arabe la
mémoire vive de votre smartphone et puis
le rhum c'est le stockage c'est
notamment le fait d'avoir un stockage
beaucoup trop chargé
mais rassurez vous il ya plein d'astuces
et je suis là pour vous aider à clore le
tout premier point mais le tout premier
il faut le faire dans quasiment tous les
cas quand vous rencontrez un problème
avec votre smartphone vous l'éteignez et
vous verrez alors je sais dit comme ça
ça paraît être un peu tout qu'on dit
mais évidemment monsieur gros je vous
assure que vous commencez par éteindre
votre appareil vous leurrez allumez vos
et si le problème les solutionner
oui ou non et donc qui a pas trois
quarts des cas dans beaucoup de cas en
tout cas ça va vraiment me rapporter une
vraie solution viable et ça c'est
vraiment très très bien le deuxième
point c'est de mettre à jour son os son
système d'exploitation ça va d'une
corriger des bugs qui peuvent causer des
ralentissements et quelques problèmes
que vous rencontrez vous aujourd'hui sur
votre smartphone
et croyez moi les correctifs y en a
quand même plus qu'on ne croit ça va
venir corriger des failles de sécurité
je vous conseille vraiment dès que vous
en avez la possibilité est dès lors que
de mises à jour vous est proposé de la
faire troisième point c'est la question
du stockage puisque dans beaucoup de cas
eh bien on manque un peu de stockage
parce qu'on a beaucoup de photos des
vidéos des films de l'audio beaucoup
d'application et que sais-je encore la
toute première chose je fais une petite
parenthèse la toute première chose
lorsque vous achetez vos smartphones
posez vous la question du stockage vous
allez retrouver votre smartphone un
moment ou un autre
est-ce que 64 giga de stockage c'est
suffisant pour vous est ce qu'il vous
faut 128
est ce qu'il vous faut 256 ou lorsqu'il
faut carrément 512 pour moi aujourd'hui
64 ça commence à venir leamy parce que
les zoos espèce de plus en plus lourd
parce qu'on a de plus en plus de photos
parce qu'on télécharge de la musique
parce qu'on télécharge des films et au
bout d'un moment c'est un petit peu
délicat alors à moins d'avoir une
extension de mémoire pouvoir venir
augmenter votre capacité de stockage
auquel cas ça peut être bien sinon
pensez quand même un grand minimum de
128 go de stockage
c'est pas un luxe maintenant ce qui est
important c'est de réussir à identifier
le problème et a regardé qu'est-ce qui
prend de la place je vous montre
l'exemple sur ios mais c'est exactement
la même chose sur android vous allez
dans vos réglages vous allez sur un os
dans général vous descendez dans
stockage iphone et là alors moi j'ai une
version monstrueuse un g1 512 giga
autant vous dire qu'il est pas remplie g
gars de prix vous allez tout de suite
vous rend compte qu est ce qui prend de
la place dans votre smartphone est ce
que c'est la partie application est ce
que c'est la partie photo et puis des
fois il ya beaucoup de l'autre on sait
pas ce que c'est sur android nous fait
la même chose vous allez dans stockage
vous allez dans libérer de l'espace et
vous trouvez ça très facilement leur
après ça dépend de vos surcouche mais
l'idée c'est un peu ça vous trouvez le
stockage pour garder ce qui prend de la
place
rassurez vous même si vous avez beaucoup
d'applications qui prennent beaucoup de
place et bien il ya des solutions à tous
la première chose c'est de venir vider
le cache de vos applications je prends
un exemple une application comme
facebook comme messenger peuvent avoir
tendance à augmenter de taille au fur et
à mesure du temps venez vider le cache
pour récupérer l'espace de stockage
regardez là si vous regardez par exemple
qu'aux pros je vois que j'ai 3,6 gia
netflix de giga spotify un giga netflix
par exemple on voit les choses un petit
coup d'oeil voyez dans l'app j'ai des
vieilles séries que je pas regardé j'ai
regardé mon garçon des stops donc pas
sur mon smartphone et tout ça j'en ai
plus du tout besoin
ce que je sais que je supprime tous
directement ici supprimez supprimez
supprimez et voyez là rien qu'en faisant
ça déjà j'étais à deux gigas je me
retrouve à aller passer tout en bas je
la vois même plus elle s'est cachée je
suis à 195 méga voilà donc tout de suite
ça écrème beaucoup beaucoup mieux et
puis faire ça avec beaucoup
d'application spotify
j'ai beaucoup de musique aussi qui est
intégré les photos n'en parlons pas on
verra ça après gopro la même manière
j'ai des fichiers qui sont intérieur est
pareil les messages souvent les pièces
jointes
j'ai beaucoup de photo gd vidéo peut
venir supprimer mes pièces jointes
volumineuses je peux gagner 350 m o donc
vous voyez il ya des petites actions
comme ça qui vous permettent de vider
vos applications tout mis bout à bout
c'est récupéré pas mal de stockage
ce qu'il faut aussi savoir pour unis la
place c'est que vos photos prennent
beaucoup de place au fait de plus en
plus de photos que soient des souvenirs
personnels des vidéos décidé ça on en
fait et elles sont toutes stocker de
l'eau smartphone alors je sais pas si
vous faites comme moi mais moi j'ai
souvent deux trois quatre prises pour
avoir la bonne photo qui convient et je
ne supprime pas les autres ce qui fait
qu'à la fin j'ai un nombre de photos qui
ne sert à rien je ne regarderai jamais
qui prend beaucoup de place et c'est
pénible
prenez l'habitude de les supprimer au
fur et à mesure pour ne garder que le
nécessaire et que ce qui est important
pour vous de la même manière prenez un
stockage dans le cloud pour ne pas tout
avoir dans votre smartphone
il ya deux vertus principales la
première c'est de libérer l'espace dans
cette petite machine
et puis deuxième point c'est si un jour
votre machine elle brûle ou vous la
changer eh bien vous récupérez tout
extrêmement facilement souvent sur des
petits abonnement de l'ordre de un ou
deux heureux quelque part moi rebonds ça
fonctionne ce que je vous conseille et
ce qui marche pas très bien cette
supprimer les applications que vous
n'utilisez pas je sais pas si vous êtes
comme moi si vous êtes un gros
consommateurs d'applications et vous en
avait des tonnes et voyez tout ça je
sais pas combien j'en utilise mais même
pas la moitié
donc si vous n'avez plus de places
supprimées ce que vous n'utilisez pas ça
va venir libérer de l'espace et pour
vous identifier
tasha les applications qui sont pas mal
je vous montre ici sur l'app store sur
mon iphone c'est ce qu'on appelle des
caches cleaner ça va venir nettoyer
votre cash alors ça peut paraître un peu
magique comme ça mais pas nécessairement
par exemple vous regardez la première
smart client nettoyeurs qui s'avoue
venir nettoyer votre cash supprimer les
fichiers qu'ils vous servent à rien il
vous le marqua nettoyage intelligent en
un seul clic organiser les photos les
vidéos les contacts fusionner les
doublons de contact envoyer masquer les
photos de contact supprimer les vidéos
volumineuse supprimer les photos inutile
et croyez moi je vous le dis en a un
paquet ce genre d'applications sont
vraiment intéressantes pour vous aider à
organiser et à gérer ça très facilement
vous voyez déjà une fois que vous avez
libérer de l'espace dans vos smartphones
et bien votre martins da pouvoir
respirer va pouvoir marcher beaucoup
mieux c'est rapide c'est immédiat ces
pratiques merci à vous merci monsieur
creux n'hésitez pas à laisser un jour
les pousse maintenant il ya un autre
truc qui est aussi je fais quelque chose
en même temps il ya des trucs qui est
extrêmement important et qui marche bien
vous pouvez désactiver l'actualisation
des applications en arrière-plan
pour vous n'ayez pas de mise à jour qui
se fasse et que ça consomme moins de
ressources nous montre ici sur iphone
mais c'est le même principe sur android
vous allez dans général vous allez d'en
actualiser en arrière-plan que vous avez
ici et vous voyez toutes les
applications qui vont venir s'actualise
en arrière-plan alors vous pouvez garder
celles que vous voulez vraiment qui
s'actualise qui sont importantes tout
les autres voulaient désactivée par
défaut
ça vous évitera d'abord des applis qui
bossent en tâche de fond autre chose que
je vous conseille sur android c'est
devenir supprimer tous les widgets que
vous avez mis sans votre écran qui
viendraient consommer davantage de
ressources
si vous avez une machine qui rament
n'allez pas lui rajouter des choses qui
vont venir consommer davantage
un autre point sur android qui marche et
qui est pas mal c'est de venir
désactiver des animations il faut que
vous veniez petit v
les outils pour les développeurs vous
tapez cette fois là vous voyez c'est
simple ça marche bien c'est rapide vous
descendez et vous allez désactiver les
animations les transitions ça venir
soulager un peu votre smartphone de la
même manière éviter ces 7e pointe qu'en
septième point évitez les fonds d'écran
dynamiques tout ce qui va venir
consommer de la ressource est à
proscrire dès lors que vous manqué
justement de ressources et le huitième
point le huitième point si une fois que
vous avez fait tout ça vous continuer à
voir des pros nouveau smartphone ce que
je vous conseille c'est de faire une
remise à zéro vous me sauvegarder tous
vos données votre calendrier vos photos
tout ce que vous voulez vous sauvegardez
tout et vous me formater l'ensemble pour
réinstaller
vous verrez si les problèmes sont
toujours présents ça pourrait venir
solutionner pas mal de problèmes et
ensuite vous partez sur une installation
neuve vous devrez installer que les
applications qui sont vraiment
nécessaires et indispensables pour vous
on va maintenant passer à la partie des
bonus parce que oui pas mal de bonus pas
mal de choses à voir quand votre
smartphone tourne eh bien on va pouvoir
regarder on voit qu'on a beaucoup
d'applications ouvertes et on se dit est
ce que tu as un trip a un peu ramé la
machine est ce que j'ai pas intérêt à
venir supprimer tout ça rassurez-vous
aujourd'hui les os ce soit à un os ou
android
j a extrêmement bien toutes ces
applications elles ne vont pas
fonctionner elles ne vont pas consommé
ne vous dit pas qu'il faut les fermer
pour les rouvrir le moment où on aurait
besoin
ça ne sert à rien c'est très bien gérée
directement par votre os à moins que
vous ayez des applications comme ruiz
qui consomment énormément ou des pokemon
godet ce nom pour le reste vous pouvez
ségur absolument aucun problème de la
même manière si votre smartphone ram et
que vous n'êtes pas à l'aise avec
installer un facebook et pouvait
installer des versions lite que ce soit
facebook lite que ce soit les sunlights
que ce soit skype lite
c'est dur à dire skype lite google go
qui seront beaucoup plus léger sur votre
smartphone si maintenant vous avez un
smartphone de gaming et qu'il commence à
ramer bon normalement si vous avez un
smartphone de gaming vous avez beaucoup
de performances vous avez des modes
gaming qui sont dédiés dans qu'elle
faisait pour mettre turbo au niveau de
la carte graphique au niveau du
processeur gpu cpu pour aller toujours
plus vite là c'est plus parce que vous
avez à priori un problème est ce parce
que vous voulez aller encore plus loin
d'ailleurs en parlant de ça ne cherchez
pas à over clock et vos smartphones je
vous le déconseille donc ça vous oubliez
d'ailleurs les applications qui vous
disent qu'elles vont overclockée votre
machine des apps que vous téléchargez
dans votre catalogue d'applications tout
ça vous ne regardez pas c'est des
conneries ça ne va pas venir overclockée
votre machine ça ne marchera pas c'est
pas vrai il y aussi les applications qui
vous disent qu'elles vont bien libérer
de la ram directement une fois de plus
ça vous laissez tomber puisque votre
rêve va gérer ça tout seul très bien
sans aucun problème
notre pied pas mal notamment chez one
plus des dans vos paramètres vous allez
dans ce système et ils ont leur âme
boost vous pouvez venir active est ici
et laurent bousses c'est bien parce que
ça veut dire améliorer la gestion de la
ram ça va venir
la booster un point qui est essentiel
auquel on ne pense pas à ces pensées
toujours à garder de l'espace libre dans
votre smartphone c'est pour ça qu'il
faut venir vider vos applications trier
vos photos supprimées les abdos vous
n'avez pas besoin puisque il vous faut
de l'espace libre c'est permettra à
votre machine de respirer de se sentir
bien et ça vous solutionnera beaucoup de
problèmes voilà pour ces quelques
astuces j'espère que ça vous aura
intéressé il ya plein de choses à savoir
sur des petites choses qui mis bout à
bout vous permettront de libérer
l'espace dans votre machine permettront
de lui permettre de se sentir beaucoup
mieux est d'avoir au final un smartphone
beaucoup plus rapide dites-moi si ces
quelques astuces vous auront intéressés
pour le marc hé bien évidemment en bas
en commentaire quant à nous on se trouve
extrêmement rapidement pour continuer à
parler d'eux tech donner des astuces ya
plein de choses qui arrivent il ya
quelque chose à dire et on continue en
mode radio canada sur ce je vous
embrasse fait des gros bisous je vous en
rendez vous dès demain vous allez di
meco ciao ciao ciao
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]